Nearly 7.4 billion people share the Earth.
One in ten live on less than $2 a day.
One in nine don't have enough food.
In developing countries, infectious diseases are the biggest killers:...
...respiratory infections, malaria, AIDS but there are solutions.
Deaths caused by malaria have decreased by 60% since 2000.
And today, researchers in Tanzania hope to eliminate it completely...
...with a range of new inventions,...
...including a mosquito-repellent chair.
In the past decade, the number of undernourished people has dropped by 100 million.
And cellphone networks being used in Kenya, Uganda and Peru...
...could help further eliminate hunger.
Global problems are improving but there's still much work to be done.
So, what happens next?
Are you ready, sir?
Okay.